I expect that no one of you found every one of these defects.
But that, the class as a whole noticed most or all of these problems.
I also expect that some of you have noticed problems that are not on the list.
The point is that groups do better than individuals.
This is sometimes called the many eyes phenomenon.
There's a cost, however.
If 200 people each look at 13 lines of code for
15 minutes, this amounts to more than one week of staff time.
At current loaded salary rates, this might cost a company thousands of dollars.
Is it worth it to a company to spend that much money to find these problems?
Would a smaller group size have worked just as well?
Would more time per person have worked better?
Notice also that there were all kinds of defects.
I intentionally didn't tell you in advance what the word defect meant,
but here there were bugs.
There were documentation issues.
There were inefficiencies, and there were even violations of coding standards.
Software engineers have studied defect detection and
concluded that team review efforts can be cost effective way to find defects.
However, the reviews must be done in a systematic fashion.